let's go to some of the notable
discussions happening over on the David
Pakman show
subreddit nearly 15,000 of our viewers
and listeners are now participating in
moderated respectful political
discussion at david pakman.com slash
reddit thats re d di t very interesting
post pointing out or asserting that if
fox news wasn't a thing trump would have
been impeached by now i actually i agree
but this is a bit too simplistic and
what i mean by that is fox by itself has
actually particularly over the last six
months not been the 100% reflexive Trump
defending tools that they were for the
latter part of the 2016 election and the
early part of the Trump presidency I
would sort of frame in a different
different way the broader right-wing
media reinforced by social media
algorithms echo-chamber
is what is very different now than when
richard nixon was under impeachment in
the 1970s so it's not fox news by itself
although fox news at least the opinion
shows that still love the guy like
Hannity and Laura Ingraham and you know
whoever else they are still a big part
of it but it's the broader ecosystem
that exists where you can have folks who
are only watching the Fox News shows
that support Trump and they're watching
you know one American news and they're
sharing fake news on Facebook and the
algorithm is reinforcing that with
articles from Breitbart and you know
whoever else that is the broader it's
it's I would I would say it's more than
Fox News but you are completely right in
that it is that ecosystem that is one of
the big differences between impeachment
around Richard Nixon in the 1970s and
Trump now and we will see ultimately
what it does for Trump once we know the
sort of full scope and final results of
the impeachment inquiry that is going on
right now
also from the david pakman show
subreddit finally Pat guests hosts the
show user PDX pro courier saying I would
much rather see Pat hosting the show
than Ferren cuz
Benjamin Dixon I like those guys nothing
against them but Pat is the og yeah and
then they go on to say things that I
won't say just because our show is you
know broadcast on FCC regulated radio
stations Pat did a great job
I had my emergency appendectomy a week
ago and I completely missed the Thursday
show Pat was able to put together a
compilation episode with a nice
introduction and he hosted the bonus
show he hosted the bonus show on Friday
and actually did a couple stories for
you on Friday Pat did a fantastic job
and we are exploring we are exploring
other spots where you may be able to see
more Pat for people who don't like Pat
and of course there are people in the
audience who like and dislike anybody
who's ever been on the show myself
included don't worry you are still going
to be able to avoid Pat if that is your
priority but know Pat did a great job
and I really appreciate all the comments
not only wishing me well recovering from
my appendectomy but also the positive
comments about Pat join the discussion
more than 15,000 other viewers and
listeners are participating at david
pakman.com slash our EDD IT